today on the Matt Walsh show believe all
women has been reborn except now it's
been racialized as well before we were
told that we must believe all women who
claim that they were sexually assaulted
or harassed now we're told that we must
believe any non-white person who claims
they're the victim of racism but this
idea is just as dangerous and irrational
as believe all women will talk about why
also 5 headlines including a true
American hero I don't use that phrase
lightly who stood up against a couple of
women at the store who were hectoring
him over not wearing a mask you have to
see the video if you haven't seen it
play that for you and in our daily
cancellation I will cancel the makers of
a children's toy for causing me
life-threatening injuries and it's a
very important kanbei probably the most
important one yet because it's so
personal to me all of that is on the way
on the show today but before that I want
to tell you about our new sponsors cars
for kids you know some of us have been
taking time during our time being at
home going through finding we have a lot
of stuff cluttered around the house that
we don't need and what's a good thing to
do with that rather than throwing it
away of course you could donate it if
you have a car that's taking up space
sitting in your driveway sitting in your
garage whatever it is you're paying
insurance on I have one question for you
why why is it just sitting there
get rid of it donate it to cars for kids
many of you have heard the jingle it's a
real ear worm I'm I'm being told here to
sing it or hum it I you know I just
can't the thing is my singing voice I
have been told causes the listener to
plunge into despair and give up the will
to live and I wouldn't want to do that
to you or to the great people at cars
for kids so you'll have to take their
word for it but you can get a tax
deduction and a vacation voucher here's
how it works cars for kids makes the
process of donating your car quick and
easy it takes us about two minutes to do
they handle all the details all the
paperwork they're taking that off your
plate all you need to do is schedule
pick up and sign the title simple as
that pickups are contact free just leave
just you leave your sign title with your
keys in the car to avoid unnecessary
contact the cars for kids driver will
conveniently pick up your car while
maintaining a safe distance donating
your car's tax deductible your tax
deduction is based on the sale price of
your car
kars4kids works hard to sell your car
for the best price which means more
funds for their charity and a bigger tax
deduction for you and as a special thank
you for donating your car kars4kids
gives you a vacation voucher good for a
three-day two-night hotel stay so I mean
you just it's a win-win-win for
everybody involved with cars for kids
you get professional serve as a
convenient pick up maximum tax deduction
a vacation voucher and a good deed all
that wrapped into one donate today at
kars4kids org slash Walsh that's cars
with a K kar s the number for K IDs dot
org slash Walz they'll give you the
donation experience that you deserve
Kars for kids dot org slash Walsh
alright so the me to movement with its
believe all women slogan has been reborn
resurrected only more like Frankenstein
than Jesus Christ in this in this case
what we can look forward to now in our
culture is a racialized version of the
same concept we've already seen it of
course playing out but I think it's only
going to get worse which is why it's
it's worth spending some time on today
talking about it and I'm gonna focus to
frame this discussion focus especially
on an article in The Wall Street Journal
just published says what does being an
ally look like companies offer training
in support of black colleagues and then
it says it acknowledged past mistakes
and questioned workplace practices to
support the advancement of black
co-workers corporate leaders say and in
a posting to Twitter the journal
provides in the caption this quote from
the article says if a black person tells
you that they're feeling something is
racist just believe them so we'll get to
that in a moment but first let's let's
read a bit from this article as we work
up to that it says difficult
conversations with colleagues about
their experiences are a critical part of
being an ally in the workplace miss
Schuyler said we have to allow people to
voice what they've been through in the
physical and mental exhaustion she said
you have to be uncomfortable every
single day or not going to get this
right miss Schuyler Shannon Schuyler by
the way she's the chief purpose and
inclusion officer at
PricewaterhouseCoopers
purpose and inclusion officer how do you
get that job and how much does it pay
I'm gonna bet well into the six figures
to be a purpose and inclusion officer
prompted by protests after the killing
of George Floyd in Minneapolis many
corporate leaders are evaluating how
best to advocate for underrepresented
employees as part of a broader diversity
and inclusion effort from tech giant
Microsoft Corp to law firm Winston and
strong companies are availing plans to
provide training and host discussions
about the concept of a lie ship allied
trading promotes the idea that an ally
generally someone who is white or
otherwise in the majority supports the
workplace advancement of people who are
black or otherwise in the minority and
stands up for them when they experience
discrimination or unfair treatment by
the way this article is doing that new
thing where black is capitalized but
white isn't there is no grammatical
defense of that whatsoever right that
really neither words should be
capitalized but if you're gonna
cannibalize when you capitalize the
other there's there's no grammatical
reason to do this it's just that the
left injects ideology into every single
crack and crevice of the national
conversation that it can everything is
turned into an ideological issue even
what words you capitalize and that's one
of the reasons why the Left wins all the
time by the ways that they're they're
making everything into an ideological
fight and they're fighting they're gonna
have fights that are so petty and
ridiculous seemingly that normal people
won't even engage so another classic
example I'm getting away from this I'll
get back to in a second but another
another example just for the last few
days is this the thing with the Goya
company that makes you know most people
know them for their for their beans
that's that's why that's why I buy their
cans of beans but the the CEO said that
he supports Trump and now there's this
massive campaign against the company and
meanwhile for
most like when I'm going to buy a can of
beans it wouldn't even occur to me to
refrain from buying a certain kind of
bean because the CEO of the company that
produced it supports a politician I
don't like I don't know what politicians
my cans of beans support I don't care
it's it's just not but on the Left they
are that heady that they won't even buy
beans from you unless you sign on to all
of their doctrinal beliefs and that's
one of the reasons why they win it's
because they're gonna fight they're
gonna have fights that the rest of us
won't even participate in because we're
just too rational at times
all right let's back back to this it
says at supermarket chain Kroger one of
its workplace groups the
african-american associate resource
group developed an ally ship guide with
advice on how to support black
colleagues and recommendations for books
and movies that discuss race allies can
serve as a sounding board for peers and
work to understand where bias exists in
the organization okay so on and so forth
further on it says when white co-workers
refer to their black co-workers as being
too loud or aggressive or their
appearance doesn't fit within their
personal acceptable standards managers
need to address these microaggressions
according to Helen a boa who's a CEO of
urban Zen and new york-based clothing
beauty and home decor retailer okay well
what if they're really just being too
loud aggressive or they're out of
uniform
isn't that a possibility for anybody of
any race if a white employee is acting
that way there will be no problem with
saying so right so it's always racist to
say that of a black employee but never
racist to say it of a white employee if
that makes sense to you you're either
high or suffering from psychotic
delusions because it makes no sense
whatsoever okay and then we get to the
to the money quote will the white a
consultant who serves as the chair of a
Vermont Vermont Vermont who know why I
said it like that of a Vermont the state
of Vermont
the the chair of of Vermont oversight
Commission on mental health and law
enforcement said she has been getting
texts recently from colleagues asking
how she's doing it's nice that people
are trying to express solidarity she
said but in the absence of a meaningful
relationship such efforts can feel empty
at like empty gestures white employees
can help black co-workers by being
respectful of their experiences instead
of arguing or trying to invalidate their
feelings
she said if a black person tells you
that they're feeling something is racist
just believe them okay now this is an
important point believe them if they say
that they feel something as Reyes's
believe them well believe what exactly
believe that they feel that way
okay sure if someone says they feel a
certain way or don't feel a certain way
all you can do is believe them I'm with
you on that and why is that because
because nobody else can speak for
someone else's feelings other than the
person experiencing those feelings
that's the only person who could be an
authority on the feelings that are being
felt yes I agree but you see what that
means that that that idea invalidates
the claim that we just heard and I'll
explain why in just a second but first
blink sale this video this show is
sponsored by blinks of the revolutionary
invoicing software that's changing the
landscape for small businesses and
independent contractors everywhere you
know the the American Dream is owning
and building a successful business
that's that's how you could really have
freedoms when you have your own business
you're doing what you love providing
something to your community but many
businesses owners know that there are
many moving parts with business in there
there are things about owning a business
from what I've heard from business
owners that you didn't even you didn't
even think would be a challenge that end
up being a bigger challenge and you
thought something simple like invoicing
keeping track of the invoicing you know
getting the invoices together all of
that stuff could be very difficult and
that's why you need blink sell blink
sell with blink sell you can send
beautiful custom branded invoices and
estimates in seconds you can
stay on top of your outstanding invoices
you can let your customers and clients
easily pay your invoices online you'll
even get instant notification when a
customer opens your invoices you'll
actually know if they're just avoiding
paying you or not
and here's also something you can do you
can get $10 blink sales gonna give $10
to 500 daily wire fans here's how to get
it go to blank sale comm start your
14-day free trial
create your first invoice of $10 and
activate an online payment option send
the invoice to daily wire at blank sale
comm and get paid your $10 the first 500
people to set an invoice for $10 to
Delhi wire at blink sale comm will get
their invoice paid now stop wasting time
invoicing and try blink sale for free @
blink sale comm / Walsh that's BL I NK s
al e comm / Walsh blink sale spend less
time billing and more time doing what
you love okay so
the claim being made here is that is
that you can't if somebody feels a
certain way you you you have to believe
how they feel it take them at their word
essentially and I agree with that
but the problem is at least for the
claim made here that the person being
accused of saying or doing something
racist is also the only person who can
verify that claim in other words when
you say that a statement or action is
racist you're making a claim not about
your own feelings but about the feelings
of the person who did or said the thing
you might feel like it was racist but
whether or not it actually is racist
well that goes to the feelings and
intentions of the person who did or said
it that's what you're really making a
claim about their emotional state about
their intentions and the only person who
can speak to that as we just covered the
only authority on that subject is the
person themselves in lieu of
mind-reading capabilities only the
person being accused is an authority on
the subject of their own alleged racism
so you feel something is racist okay you
feel that fine
but your feelings about someone else's
feelings have no evidentiary value
whatsoever if I want to know whether
something was racist I'm not gonna go
talk to other people to see how it made
them feel because that's not gonna tell
me whether or not it actually was racist
your feelings about my feelings don't
prove anything at all about my feelings
it's true that I can lie about my
feelings and it's true sometimes that my
actions can speak so clearly to a
certain feeling or intention that my
claims after the fact have to be treated
skeptically so for example if I if I
walk up to you out of the blue and punch
you in the face
and then later on I say I didn't mean to
hurt you in that case you would be
justified in feeling skeptical about my
claims that's because there's almost no
other conceivable reason why you would
why I would
up to a person and punch him in the face
so you as the punchy are left to surmise
either that the puncher wanted to do you
arm or they're insane there really isn't
any third option maybe they were like
aggressively tried to swat a mosquito
away from your nose but you know that
that again seems dubious so there are
nuances here but even so the only true
authority on a person's feelings and
intentions is the person if that
authority chooses not to be honest or to
conceal the truth then that's what
they're gonna do but they are still the
only authority the rest of us can only
guess surmise theorize come to tentative
conclusions but we can't know the way
the person can know and all of that
means that that that in a situation
where there could be any number of
reasonable ways to explain a person's
actions when a person you know when a
person's actions could plausibly be
motivated by good or bad or neutral
intentions and this is the case most of
the time I mean with most of the things
people do especially in their
interactions with other people there's
any number of ways to interpret it and
in those cases all you can do is listen
to their own account of their own
actions their explanation and accept it
so a really good example from this
article it says that it's a
microaggression and it's racist to tell
a black employee that they're being too
loud okay well if someone in a work
environment says to another person
you're being too loud seems to me that
there's any number of reasons why person
might say that
one reason I guess is that they're
racist and that they're you know they're
trying to shut up a black person because
the rich racist that is a possibility I
guess but there are a lot of other
possibilities too one possibility is
that the person is really just being too
loud and others in their work
environment can't focus that's a
possibility
there may even be you know options C D
and E here I don't know it's possible to
the person saying you're being too loud
does have ill intentions but that aren't
racially based maybe they have a
personal animus against this person
maybe it's you know some
passive-aggressive data and an
individual they don't like I mean
they're any number of reasons why the
person who said you're being too loud
might have said that and in that case
given that there are so many possible
explanations so many plausible
explanations and in fact the most
plausible and immediate explanation is
totally innocent you know the most
plausible to me the explanation being
the person is really just being too loud
nothing to do with their race they're
just being too loud as people contend to
be in a workplace environment in that
case it doesn't make any sense for
someone to say well I feel like it was
racist so it was no all we can do if you
really suspect that there might be a
racist reason for that to be said then
all you can do is ask the person why did
you say that and they could tell you now
you might say if they meant it in a
racist way they're not gonna admit it
yeah maybe so but even an act but but
but even so they are the only authority
no one else can be an authority okay if
if if samantha is saying you're it says
something to Tammy and we want to know
why Samantha said that thing it doesn't
make any sense to ask Tammy we have to
ask Samantha right Tammy's not the one
who said it samantha is but you know I'm
trying to explain all of this and going
to great lengths to be logical about it
but of course it doesn't matter because
as I said before this is all ideology
and the left injects ideology into
everything part of their ideology of
course is that every white person is
racist inherently doesn't matter what
you feel or how you think you're
everyone is racist and therefore
everything you do could be and probably
is at some level races especially if
you're interacting with or
it anyway dealing with someone of
another race so it's also really it's
all racist and in another part of that
ideology is that somehow the white
people have this inherent racism most of
them are too stupid or too blind to even
see it within themselves and so they
need other people to enlighten them all
ideology based no logic to it no
rationality whatsoever but that's what
makes the world turn these days let's go
to headlines number one the the esteemed
Alexandra o kzr Cortez the esteemed
scholar has a theory as to why violent
crime is on the water rise and here's
here's her theory so why is this
happening well let's think about it do
we think this has to do with the fact
that there's record unemployment in the
United States right now the fact that
people are at a level of economic
desperation that we have not seen since
the Great Recession maybe this has to do
with the fact that people aren't paying
their rent and are scared to pay their
rent and so they go out and they need to
feed their child and they don't have
money so you maybe have to they're put
in a position where they feel like they
either need to shoplift some bread or go
hungry that night
shoplifting bread sure you know except
the problem is that the crimes on the
rise are not bread thefts
I'm not aware of any statistic about
bread being stolen at a higher rate than
usual I'm not I'm not aware of that
happening no the crimes that are on the
rise are crimes like this the community
is up in arms as you might imagine the
overs is tragic and senseless murder of
a 22 month old I just got the update
from the New York City Police Department
they tell me this little boy it was
identified as a novella
lived here in Brooklyn in Brownsville
however he was at a cookout with family
members here on Madison Street overnight
it was around 11:30 and you can see this
morning that little boy's stroller still
on the sidewalk police telling me he was
sitting there when two men walked up and
just started firing into the crowd that
little boy was shot in the stomach he
was rushed to an area hospital where
doctors could not save him from that
gunshot wound to the stomach three other
people here at this cookout were also
wounded three adult men they are
expected to be ok witnesses telling me
that they saw these suspects sprint away
possibly into a waiting vehicle on
Marcus Garvey Boulevard this was just a
1 of 35 people shot over this weekend
and clearly people in the community are
incensed two years old less than two
actually a baby shot in the stomach
killed at a barbecue with his family
added to the list of children very young
children in many cases who've been
murdered in our cities over the last few
weeks and let's be clear about about
what AOC is doing here ok she is looking
to distract from from from this by
dressing this kind of crime up as you
know a downtrodden person stealing bread
now she wasn't talking specifically
about this case when she said that but
she was justifying the rise in crime and
the rise in crime has been a rise in
this kind of crime and she knows that it
has been a rise in violent crime against
often innocent children or other members
of the community and usually the black
community that's the crime we're dealing
with and she's trying to justify it
number two there were protests at
speaking of justifying crimes there were
protests in Detroit over the weekend of
our man named Akeem Littleton who was
shot and killed by police
protesters whereas as this nbc's
headline says demanding justice here's
some footage of that peaceful protest of
people who just want nothing but justice
in the world watch
[Applause]
so peaceful so soapy actually several
cops were assaulted during that peaceful
protest because you know they these
protesters were so distraught over a
Keene Middleton that they had no choice
but to assault police officers the only
problem which isn't really a problem for
the protesters who couldn't care less
about the truth obviously but still the
issue here is that despite the testimony
of eyewitnesses who say the hakim was
was gunned down unarmed you know despite
that he was actually in reality pulling
a gun and firing it at police officers
here's the video of that altercation
this weekend parts of Detroit on edge as
protesters demand justice for Hakim
Littleton the 20 year old shot and
killed by police Friday afternoon the
outrage set off after claims on social
media accusing Detroit Police of killing
an unarmed man authorities responded by
releasing - and body cam footage showing
members of the police gang squad
approaching and arresting Darnell
Sylvester wanted on a federal drug
warrant while he complies authorities
say Littleton standing nearby appears to
pull out a weapon and stated this body
cam footage appears to show Littleton
shooting at an officer and missing
before police returned fire he is what I
described
despite being fired he continued to
advance the police chief says he
released videos to set the record
straight
but even after these images became
public protesters still want answers
[Music]
Kathy Park NBC News
so cops were making an arrest of someone
else Akeem was there decided to take the
opportunity to try and execute a cop you
can clearly see him pulling a gun and
firing and then he was shot and killed
so thank God the police were able to
take him down before any of before he
was able to successfully murder any of
them he's the bad guy here cut-and-dry
it's it's it's sad that he decided to
throw his own life away hit a fool that
he made that choice but there's no
outrage here there's no injustice and
once again you know it's it just feels
hopeless after a while because this
doesn't matter either
I mean you if you were dealing with
rational people and there was a protest
over a police shooting and then a video
came out proving that the person who was
shot was shooting at police that would
be the end of it and the protesters if
they were rational people and also maybe
not even being rational isn't even the
issue if they were really concerned
about police brutality if that was
actually the concern then they would say
okay you know we got this one wrong
sorry to the police officers you word
you know you're defending yourselves
obviously thank you for keeping our
community safe we'll go home people who
were really concerned about police
brutality that's how they would respond
but these protesters of course don't
care about police brutality at all it's
got nothing to do with it for a lot of
them it's just an excuse a you know a
forum for wreaking destruction and all
of that and then we know for BLM and and
the leaders of this movement they've got
a lot of a lot on their plate agenda
wise in police brutality has almost
nothing to do with any of it number
three let's go over to the UK to talk
about soccer which which you know it's a
great activity for people who don't like
sports Crystal Palace winger Wilfried
Zaha I don't know what
any of those words mean a winger sounds
like something you'd order at Applebee's
I don't know but anyways aha recently
posted online some screenshots of racist
messages that he received from someone
and they are certainly very racist and
objectionable messages the police got
involved when tracked down the source of
these messages
turns out the culprit was a 12 year old
boy a 12 year old who's sending me
messages to a grown man a soccer player
now in a sane world the story ends there
the boy's parents deal with his bad
behavior maybe ground him take away his
videogames you know something like that
and the rest of the world moves on but
we don't live in such a world so instead
the police arrested the 12 year old boy
for the bad things he wrote online and
nobody seems to have any problem with
this either the police department issued
a statement saying the twelve-year-old
arrested in connection with racist
social media messages sent to a
footballer has been has been released
under investigation while our inquiries
continue racism has no place in our
society and we're attempting to contact
the footballer to obtain a stain so
they're still investigating what is
there to investigate it was a 12 year
old saying bad stuff
zom Saha also is not stepping in you
know this is where if it were me I would
step in and say hey yo okay guys we
don't need to a rat I didn't realize as
a 12 year old listen we don't need to
arrest prepubescent children for saying
bad things let's let's let's just let's
let's calm down okay that's not what
Zaha saying he's fully on board
here's his statement he says very
disappointed we didn't get a better
result yesterday but I wanted to come on
here to thank all of you for your
messages and support all would also like
to thank the West Midlands Police for
their swift action and making an arrest
people need to understand that whatever
your age your behavior and your words
come with consequences and you cannot
hide behind social media so he's fully
on board with with with arresting a 12
year old Hodgson is the manager of the
soccer team he says it's very saddening
on the day of a game that a player wakes
up to this cowardly and despicable abuse
I think it's right that people who are
made aware of it I don't think this is
something we should keep quiet about
there is literally no excuse there is no
excuse at all
cowardly despicable actions you're
talking about a 12 year old here and
then doing a cursory glance online
looking at the comments on Sky News the
Sky News post about this the comments
are probably 90% in favor of the arrest
of a 12 year old with the caveat that
many of them are saying the parents also
should be arrested that's their problem
with this it's not the bait arrest of
the 12 year old for stuff that he wrote
online for mean comments he made to a to
a grown men it's said they didn't also
arrest the parents for it as well number
four the head writer for Tucker Carlson
show Blake Neff has resigned after
someone told the media that he Neff has
been posting anonymously on a message
board for years now and many of us posts
are racist and sexist the media has been
having a field day with this of course
and Fox news came out forcefully to
condemn Neff here's what they said we
want to make abundantly clear that fox
news media strongly condemns this
horrific racist misogynistic and
homophobic behavior Neffs abhorrent
conduct was never divulged to the show
until Friday at which point we swiftly
accepted his resignation make no mistake
actions such as this cannot be and will
not be tolerated at any time in any part
of our workforce now the interesting
thing is that the folks over at NBC have
been spiking the football over this but
NBC has just promoted joy Reed who is a
woman who on her own blog under her own
name for years posted stuff that was in
line with a lot of the things this guy
was writing particularly when it comes
to you know her comments about
homosexuals and again she was doing that
under her own name proudly for years and
rather than accept responsibility she
claimed that she'd been hacked when all
this was found out but NBC not only does
NBC not condemn and fire her but
actually they're promoting her they're
giving her more airtime and herein lies
another crucial distinction between the
left and right
Fox is tripping all over itself
condemning oh it's horrific unimaginable
terrible he's gone we're getting rid of
him while NBC grants a larger platform
to their
Oh offender its and let me just say also
by the way horrific is a word that more
accurately describes say the actions of
a serial killer
or a school shooter or someone like that
the that that's a word you pull out when
it when when something like that happens
horrific horrific actions trolling a
message board anonymously is not
horrific might be bad it might be
objectionable but yeah I really think we
should reserve a word like horrific for
actually horrific like something that
when you hear about it you are actually
horrified like you it takes your breath
away it's a horrifying
that's what horrific is I've never been
aware of any comment on a message board
that could possibly rise to that level
but you know that's just me number five
finally we must pause to honor this hero
watch you take a picture of me that make
you feel better why don't you get a life
going around taking pictures the mayor
asked us all to wear masks and look at
you not wearing a mask
Oh political it's unbelievable now you
have accosted me in this store is not a
wall that I got aware of man if you're
gonna keep this up maybe we'll get the
police department what you call nine
nine one then yeah I'm out of a tree now
you're the monkey that has it pay off
tracking those knuckles okay everybody
do I remove them evolution
why don't you go back to where you are
you burning crosses and you burning
crosses no you're the idiot doing my
shopping you're unbelievable good luck
with the virus good luck with the virus
your whole family tree is getting up and
it's roots that that man we need to
build an statue to that man and guard it
we need to put post armed guards around
the statue 24/7 so that no harm comes to
the statue but I and this is not I think
we should be clear you know we've seen a
lot of these videos with involving
people wearing masks or not wearing
masks and everything and sometimes there
are people who go in to places without
the mask on they're the ones filming and
they're trying to make a scene or a
statement have it which i think is
really stupid this is a guy he's not
looking he wasn't looking for any
attention he wasn't making a statement
or making a scene he just yeah he had he
had the shopping list from his wife in
his hand you could see there and he was
just going in to buy some stuff and he
wanted to go go about his day he wasn't
bothering anybody wasn't hurting anybody
if you're worried that he's gonna spread
a disease to you then just keep walking
go to a different aisle avoid him
if you're really scared about you don't
surround him and get within six feet and
start shouting at him get into a
shouting match that's that's not what
you would do if you're really worried
that someone's gonna spread a disease to
you but I thought he handled that just
every every part of the way he handled
that was great and that is just that's a
classic dad right there okay he's got
the t-shirt tucked in the jorts the
glorious beer gut it's got the white
shoes the socks pulled up you know
shopping list from his wife had on okay
that is that is a dead and you don't
tangle you don't tangle with a classic
dad some of these New Age dads maybe you
could you could get away with that but
the
not this dead those ladies they should
have known that okay this is not go pick
on someone else and you know what else
is gonna happen I guarantee this okay
that guy went home and either didn't
mention this event at all to his wife or
told her about it in about three minutes
and then went outside to mow the grass
and that was it and he stopped thinking
about it meanwhile those women I
guarantee you they went home to their
tortured husbands and and told them this
story in about a three hour long saga
you know the story taking a hundred
times longer than the actual event
itself that it's meant to describe and
and are still talking then called all
their friends and they're gonna be telic
talking about it at Thanksgiving
guaranteed but then again as a man if
you choose to marry a woman like that I
guess you really bring it on yourself
let's go to our finally our daily
cancellation today in what is probably
my most important cancellation today
I'll be cancelling the makers of
slip-and-slide for causing the injuries
that I'm currently suffering from we got
a slip inside a Finding Nemo slip and
slide to be precise and because I'm a
loving father I decided that I needed to
try it out and just test it to make sure
it's safe you know the say the same same
philosophy of course with with like with
Halloween candy you know you always
always make sure that I eat about half
of it just to really be sure that
there's no poison or anything so I
tested about six or seven times again
just to ensure the safety of the device
and that's when I sustain my life
threatening injuries as this footage
recorded by my wife clearly shows this
is this is difficult to watch it's a
little bit gruesome but here it is
yes pretty awful I tumbled right over
the end of it onto the grass rolling and
flopping around like a wounded fish with
Nemo's eyes staring at me mockingly
there's not nearly enough runway on that
thing for a man my size it needs to be
about 50 or 60 feet longer now some
people have told me that slip and slides
are not made for 34 year-old men and
that actually there's a huge warning
label right on it saying don't use this
if you're over the age of 12 fatal
injury could occur others told me I
shouldn't have put it on a hill others
told me I shouldn't be wearing a shirt
for water activities like a fat kid all
of this is nothing but victim shaming
and body shaming you know the fact that
any of you would rationalize my abuse
and take the side of my abuser slip and
slide just shows how much work we have
yet to do in the society we think we've
made progress but we have not made
nearly enough progress I have three
broken ribs a ruptured spleen a
punctured lung or at least I feel like
that's what I have which is the same
thing as having it and I blame everyone
for this I blame the makers of subs
inside I blame my children who are all
cancelled as well I mean they're the
ones who cheered me on you know they
should have known that I was putting my
life at risk and stepped in to prevent
it my three-year-old was standing there
just applauding why didn't he stand in
the way and say no father I can't let
you do this the results will be
calamitous desist father I beg you why
did he say that my nine month old is
just is just sitting there sat in
silence silence is violence said nothing
my wife needless to say also is canceled
so everybody is canceled
I and and I will do my best to heal for
my injuries but I just want to say it's
it's not just my physical injuries as
horrendous as those are it's the
emotional injuries and the feeling of
betrayal that I now that I now must live
for the rest of my life and we'll leave
it on that rather sad note thanks for
watching everybody thank you for
listening I got to go I supp Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there